de vuelta a su lugar de origen los
restos de siete de los migrantes
fallecidos en el incendio de un centro
de detención en México llegaron a su
país El Salvador José Amílcar solorzano
era una de las 40 personas detenidas en
Ciudad Juárez Su objetivo era ir rumbo
Norte en busca del llamado sueño
americano en el sueño de él que es su
familia estuviera mejor que sus hijas
sacaran la universidad
igual la mamá ayudará a la mamá
pues es el sueño tener una estabilidad
un poco más mejor que quizás acá no
cuesta un poco más tenerla el gobierno
de El Salvador exigió a México que se
aclaren las circunstancias como lo he
mencionado todos los migrantes merecen
un trato digno sin importar su condición
en este Marco solicitamos que el estado
mexicano investigue los hechos
violatorios a esos derechos humanos
Mientras tanto las autoridades llevan a
cabo las investigaciones como un posible
homicidio y un caso de negligencia el
gobierno de Andrés Manuel López Obrador
prometió que los responsables serían
judicializados tras conocerse un video
de seguridad que muestra como los
guardias del centro de detención no
abrieron las rejas cuando el incendio
comenzó en el video se ve como las
personas atrapadas patean Las rejas para
intentar salir mientras dos cuerdas
salen en ese momento del recinto
Posteriormente se conoció que el oficial
encargado de supervisar el ala de
detención masculina había salido del
recinto minutos antes de que se
iniciaran las llamas y no está claro si
el Guardia aportaba la llave de la celda
o si se encontraba dentro del recinto se
Han detenido a unas cinco personas
presuntamente implicadas en el suceso
entre los imputados se encuentran
funcionarios del Instituto Nacional de
migraciones y el migrante que provocó
las llamas